avec nous le pdg de dietswell jean
claude bourdon bonjour bonjour dit
souhait d'une société implantée à
guyancourt est spécialisée en ingénierie
et services de l'industrie des énergies
renouvelables et conventionnelles vous
venez d'être lauréat de la marine energy
alliance
c'est un projet de coopération
territoriale européen et c'est grâce au
développement du concept qu'on voit à
l'image que vous avez obtenu cette
reconnaissance
le trust float la production d'hydrogène
en mer alimenté par une éolienne
flottante
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi consiste ce système voyez le
plaisir tout d'abord le les projets
d'énergie éolienne offshore sont des
sujets dont on parle depuis longtemps
mais l'industrialisation un peu tard dès
aujourd'hui les choses se mettre en
place il ya quelques projets pilotes et
surtout il ya deux de grandes ambitions
de de tous les acteurs de des énergies
au sens large et des états qui ont accès
à la mer de récupérer l'énergie éolienne
offshore qui présente beaucoup beaucoup
davantage alors nous on a développé ou
comme vous le savez on vient de
l'industrie pétrolières parapétrolières
notre métier c'était d'exploiter des
plateformes de forage en mer un peu
partout autour de la planète ce qui nous
a permis d'acquérir une longue
expérience et surtout d'avoir énormément
de références cette compétence dans le
domaine offshore condat souhaité mieux
mettre à disposition des indes et des
énergies renouvelables et en particulier
de la récupération d'énergie éolienne
offshore en développant ce flotteur 3
clos alors qu'est ce que le flotteur
trust l'aude c'est une unité flottante
en fait une grosse bouée composé de
trois colonnes pour la stabilité et semi
submersible c'est à dire qu'elle est
ballast et de manière à la rendre
beaucoup plus stable
avec pour objectif de 10 places et en
son centre une éolienne de grosses
capacités
pas moins de six mégawatts ça représente
déjà des unités de grosse taille et plus
probablement dans le futur assez proche
maintenant au delà 10 mégawatts 10 12 15
mai ogawa tu sont envisagées ce qui fera
plus de même des unités qui vont faire
plus de 220 mètres en hauteur vous
imaginez la taille pratiquement la
hauteur de la tour eiffel tout ça
offshore qu'est ce que ça va permettre
ce système ça va permettre de fournir en
électricité une commune plusieurs
communes
alors évidemment il ya puisse faire
partir du moment où fait de
l'électricité vous pouvez en faire
presque vous voulez si vous pouvez la
transporter vous pouvez bien sûr nous
l'objectif c'était éventuellement de la
mettre à disposition d'utilisateurs en
mer mais on peut également en
utilisation secondaire en faire par
exemple utiliser l'électricité pour
faire des de l'hydrogène par exemple
hydrogène qui peut facilement se stocker
et transporter et pourquoi pas pour
utiliser pour être utilisé dans des
véhicules pourquoi pas dans des flottes
de transport urbain comme dans une
commune comme la nôtre par exemple ici
est ce qui pourrait être le cas dans le
futur
après l'électricité peut évidemment être
utilisée est ramené à terre connecté à
la grille mais ça ce sera dans le cadre
de ferme de grosse taille qui feront
plusieurs centaines de mégawatts dont
qui comporteront plusieurs unités comme
le troc l'autre on vient de connaître
une crise sanitaire qui a engendré une
crise économique
les gouvernants pense pouvoir relancer
l'économie notamment en investissant
dans l'environnement dans l'énergie dans
les énergies renouvelables pour relancer
aussi une activité l'activité économique
on a vu aussi que l'industrie pétrolière
a été gravement touché un parent par la
crise quel est votre regard justement
sur l'avenir sur l'investissement sur
les énergies renouvelables en tant que
spécialiste de ce sujet alors écoutez
c'est une très bonne question on avait
lancé le projet retournement des
énergies renouvelables bien avant la
crise du co lead la crise du coc vie
nous a
évidemment renforcée dans cette idée de
faire une transition vers les énergies
renouvelables
la crise du coc vidal yonhap
particulièrement violent effort sur les
industries pétrolières et
parapétrolières à la production la
consommation a baissé d'un minimum de
30% ce qui fait que tous les projets ont
été soit complètement avant et arrêtés
soient reportées au mieux et on voit pas
une reprise forte du secteur avant le
milieu de l'année prochaine au mieux
mais parallèlement les états en
encourage maintenant les la transition
vers la récupération d énergie
renouvelable ce qui est dans l'éolien
fait partie et on est très intéressé de
voir ce qui se passe à l'heure actuelle
avec des décisions fortes d'aider des
dirigeants étaient des états pour
investir massivement sur la récupération
de ces énergies éoliennes en mer merci
jean claude bourdon et dg donc de
dietswell société implantée à guyancourt
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
je vous remercie beaucoup et un je
souhaite le meilleur à cette industrie
qui est effectivement extrêmement
intéressant porteur d'avenir et
d'emplois pour les jeunes en particulier
merci